el mes de noviembre fue uno de los más
duros en eeuu las autoridades
registraron más de cuatro millones de
casos de kobe 19 dos veces más que en
octubre lo que establece un nuevo récord
de aumento mensual del virus la
autoridad en enfermedades infecciosas en
eeuu dijo que el país está en un ascenso
pronunciado de la tasa de infecciones
después de las vacaciones de acción de
gracias' por nation
lo importante es que sabemos que cuando
me tiras con máscaras con distancia sin
tener multitudes o entornos congregados
y hay estados que han hecho eso en
realidad puedes ver que la inflexión de
la curva comienza a hacer esto sabemos
que podemos hacer algo al respecto
especialmente ahora que nos adentramos
en la estación más fría y nos acercamos
a las vacaciones de navidad
los aeropuertos estuvieron llenos
durante el fin de semana de estas
vacaciones pero a pesar de lo que se
viene el alcalde de nueva york anunció
una reapertura de los colegios públicos
a partir de la próxima semana
lewis a partir de la semana del lunes 7
de diciembre las escuelas públicas de la
ciudad de nueva york comenzaron a
reabrir comenzaremos con las escuelas
primarias y nuestros centros de escuelas
públicas
y luego de esta semana el jueves 10 de
diciembre nuestro programa de educación
especial del distrito 75
los expertos advierten que es probable
que la pandemia empeore mucho más en los
próximos días antes de que una posible
vacuna pueda ofrecer algún alivio